>> Bill: THANK YOU SO MUCH.
LEADING OUR COVERAGE FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> Dana: THE NEXT GUEST IS
LEADING THE SENATE PUSH TO GET
INFORMATION OUT ON THE COVID
INFORMATION.
I THINK TO SET IT UP LET’S SHOW
AN EXCHANGE BETWEEN YOU AND DR.
FAUCI YESTERDAY.
>> SINCE YOU BELIEVE IN
TRANSPARENCY, WOULDN’T YOU
THINK THAT WE SHOULD DECLASSIFY
ALL THE INFORMATION?
>> KNOWS LIKELY SCENARIO IT WAS
A NATURAL OCCURRENCE BUT NO ONE
KNOWS THAT 100% FOR SURE.
SINCE NO ONE ABSOLUTELY KNOWS
THAT, I BELIEVE WE DO NEED THE
KIND OF INVESTIGATION WHERE
THERE IS OPEN TRANSPARENCY.
I’M NOT SURE IF IT’S MY PLACE
TO TELL THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES --
>> I THINK HE WOULD RESPECT
YOUR OPINION AS MUCH AS ANYONE.
>> Dana: SENATOR, THIS IS WHAT
I WANT TO ASK YOU.
THE INTELLIGENCE COULD INCLUDE
SOURCES AND METHODS, RIGHT?
THAT’S A POSSIBILITY THEY WOULD
HAVE TO CONSIDER.
WHAT DO YOU THINK YOU MIGHT BE
ABLE TO FIND IF WE HAD ACCESS
TO THAT PRIVATE INTEL?
>> SO NUMBER ONE, SOMETHING IS
AFOOT BECAUSE WHEN YOU GET DR.
COLLINS, DR. FAUCI, I WENT
RIGHT AFTER SENATOR KENNEDY
DRILLING IN AND THEY DID ALMOST
EVERYTHING THEY COULD TO AVOID
SAYING YES, WE NEED TO
DECLASSIFY BUT THEY KNEW THEY
COULDN’T SO WE’LL NOT ONLY FIND
OUT AND GIVE US THE TRAIL TO
START DOWN WITH INFORMATION
THAT WE OWN AND WHY WOULDN’T
YOU DO IT?
THE MORE I LOOK INTO IT, THIS
WAS SQUASHED OUT OF THE GATE BY
ECOHEALTH, N.I.H., ESPECIALLY
W.H.O. AND CHINA ITSELF.
SO THE AMERICAN PUBLIC DESERVES
IT.
THE WORLD DESERVES IT WITH ALL
THE TURMOIL THAT HAS BEEN
CAUSED BY IT.
>> Bill: SO THEN WHAT NEXT?
PETER DOOCY IN THE PRESS ROOM
YESTERDAY WITH A QUESTION AND
ANSWER.
>> WOULD THE PRESIDENT SEEK TO
PUNISH CHINA?
>> WE AREN’T GOING TO GO THERE
YET.
>> IS THAT SOMETHING THAT IF
ANOTHER NATION WAS RESPONSIBLE
FOR, KNEW MORE THAN LETTING ON,
WOULD THE PRESIDENT DO ANYTHING?
>> HE IS DOING SOMETHING RIGHT
NOW.
HE ASKED HIS TEAM BACK IN MARCH
TO DO THIS -- TO LOOK INTO THIS.
>> Bill: IN THE MEANTIME THE
CHINESE COMMUNIST PARTY SAID
CASE CLOSED.
WE’VE REACHED OUR OWN
CONCLUSIONS AND IT’S DONE AND
OVER WITH.
DO YOU EVER THINK WE’LL GET A
STRAIGHT UP ANSWER FROM THE
CHINESE GOVERNMENT?
>> IT DEPENDS ON HOW COMPELLING
ANY OF THE INFORMATION THAT IS
STARTING TO FLOAT AROUND THE
EDGES CURRENTLY.
IT IS COMPLICATED WHEN YOU TRY
TO SQUASH THIS FROM THE
BEGINNING AND WHEN TRUMP,
POMPEO AND OTHERS WANTED TO
PURSUE IT, TOM COTTON WAS
TALKING ABOUT THIS OVER A YEAR
AGO.
THERE IS A LOT OF POLITICAL
CROW YOU WOULD HAVE TO EAT TO
REALLY BE INVESTIGATING IN AN
AGGRESSIVE WAY THAT I THINK
WILL GET TO THE BOTTOM OF IT.
I’VE RESEARCHED WHAT THE ODDS
ARE ABOUT THIS COMING OUT OF A
LAB VERSUS A NATURAL INFECTION
AND CLEARLY FROM THE GET GO IT
WAS -- YOU NEEDED TO BE MORE
PRYING TO FIND OUT.
IT IS ALL CASCADING FORWARD NOW.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS A
TOUGH POLITICAL STRAIGHT YEAH
IN TRANSPARENCY LIKE I TEASED
OUT OF COLLINS AND FAUCI
YESTERDAY.
WE’LL SEE IF THEY WANT TO
INVESTIGATE OR JUST GIVE IT LIP
SERVICE.
>> Dana: HAVE WE HIT ABOUT ONE
OF THE ONLY BIPARTISAN ISSUES
IN THE SENATE RIGHT NOW?
DEMOCRATS BACK GROWING CALLS
FOR CONGRESS TO PROBE COVID LAB
THEORY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> SO WHEN YOU GET TWO
CONSERVATIVE SENATORS LIKE
MYSELF AND SENATOR HAWLEY ON
THE FLOOR OF THE SENATE AND YOU
DO NOT GET A DEMOCRAT
CONTESTING IT WHERE IT GOES
THROUGH BY UNANIMOUS CONSENT,
YOU KNOW HOW RARE THAT IS?
THAT TELLS ME THEY DID NOT WANT
TO BE ON RECORD TO AT LEAST NOT
BE INTERESTED IN TRANSPARENCY.
IT TELLS ME THAT THEY KNOW THIS
IS GOING TO BE UNLEASHED IN A
WAY WHERE THEY HAVE TO BE
ENGAGED MORE THAN THEY HAVE
BEEN IN THE PAST RATHER THAN
DISMISSING IT, BRINGING UP
WORDS LIKE XENOPHOBE I CAN, ALL
THE THINGS THEY DID BECAUSE
THEY WERE INVESTED IN THE
OPPOSITE APPROACH BECAUSE THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION HAD THE
OPPOSITE POINT OF VIEW OF
THEIRS.
AN INTERESTING EVOLUTION OVER
THE NEXT FEW DAYS AND WEEKS.
>> Bill: THANK YOU FOR YOUR